foreign
hey did you ever do a thing where you go
to a store
and you act like you just bought this
thing that you just picked off the shelf
and you go to it register and you say
hey I'd like to return this mm-hmm
you can do that how calm you was
hey buddy taught me that he just went
into Best Buy he opened up a TV box and
then he rolled it up to customer service
and said can I return this and they're
like nope and they're like oh well they
first asked if he had a receipt and he
goes oh no I don't have it I think it's
in the car and they're like oh well you
gotta go get it he takes the TV out yeah
oh he took the TV with him he took the
TV no you can't return it dude back in
the day one thing we should do was go to
Marshalls and get like Nike stuff right
and then we go to like a Nike Factory or
like a Nike outlet and return it
and then they'll give you like a gift
card a full price sometimes yeah so then
you got it for a cheaper price and then
you go only done it like once or twice
and that was the only time I did that
[__]
ladies never done anything like that no
but isn't that from the movie and then
people just started taking that running
it oh really I was like no oceans it's
she just gets out of like prison or
whatever and she she goes to like a
department store and she has all this
like really expensive perfume or
whatever and she goes to the counter and
she makes the fuss about it she's like
can I just return these and the ladies
do you have a receipt she goes no and
she's like I mean okay well like what
can you do like well without a receipt
you can't return these and she just acts
all annoyed and she's like okay well do
you at least have a bag
and then she puts it in the bag and she
takes it out how'd she get in there I
want to watch this movie now kinda
because I didn't watch that I think it's
eight it's eight it's I think it's
Ocean's eight because twelve is the is
the the second one right yeah I'm like
11 12 13 and then eight it just pissed
me off so much because they recast Danny
ocean as a woman yeah I don't like that
that's [__] up I was like yeah yeah
Danielle lotion
so I yeah it's a very common little
thing again it's hard to do it a lot
because people catch on because I think
they get your name on the an address I
think they used to do that like you know
when you return stuff what's your name I
don't know I'll give my real name my
name is Nick Dunn yeah this is my
address there's this one woman in the UK
who would run this same exact scam
nothing fancy just literally the Bare
Bones of what we're talking about and
she would go store to store doing this
but she um would open up accounts and
fake names and have all these different
IDs so she could do it for longer she
ended up doing it for four years and uh
she was able to make half a million
dollars that's [__] gangster money
this isn't the item she would steal the
items go to sometimes go to a branch of
the same brand like go to a gap here and
then go to the Gap there and then just
go hey I'd like to return this thing
that I just stole yeah and then they
would just constantly go
no receipt she could return it huh
wow the bougie places you don't need
receipts right really some of them yep
exactly she did some High Street LV or
some [__] like [__] Nordstroms and
[__] whatever and she yeah but then they
usually say okay well what car did you
purchase it from because they're gonna
need that information and then you say
yeah because actually you say I pay cash
wow
is that like a Filipino mom she's I
think sick and that's all the stuff that
she's oh she's returning that's I
thought I was like what does that do it
cools off the sickest moves yeah dude
she made tons one dude she's the
original ocean like you wanna you wanna
know what's more impressive what I used
to do bro what that Urban Outfitters
tell us I take one shirt
that's expensive it's like this is a
shirt I want I take another shirt from
the clearance rack that I'm like I don't
get I pay six dollars for this and I
swapped the tags wow tags and I'm
sweating once I [__] give them the
shirt and they they scan it and I go
just sweating like crazy and then I'm
like sir are you okay okay I'm like oh
but I seem to be sweating quite a bit
and I was like so so that one's 6.99
right this one's 699 and then they
[__] charge me and it's not good
what's um how much have you saved doing
that you think
more than half a meal probably
more impressive than whatever she did
how come you don't wear Urban
oh dude it's just like they're
Collective of like all kinds of Brands
so like just all kinds of Brands okay
you know
me and uh Urban one time I I was about
call me a liar dude call me [__] liar
being observant I was about like 12
years old yeah 12 or 13 and then
um I started learning about uh credit
card what is it called no gift card gift
card cracking or whatever right but
basically
what we did is we created fake like AOL
accounts and then we had a script where
you send out emails just to like people
in chat rooms right you just you just
spam email them all this stuff and then
um it went to like something where they
put in their credit card information to
like
re-like install their AOL or like get it
back on because you know it was like
because your trial is good yeah whatever
right
so we get these uh it's kind of like you
get these credit card uh Farm things
and then so you got the numbers and then
so you at the time you can just buy uh
gift cards from different retailers from
the mall or whatever and I found one
that it was a Westfield gift card that
you can use it on all the uh Merchants
so it wasn't just like Target or
whatever so your credit card it was any
any tenant of them all yeah and then the
funny thing is I think a younger kid
taught me this so he was a genius
because I I'm almost like 12 or 13 right
he taught me this and then he was like
let's go on a shopping spree so I was
like okay so then we just literally like
got a bunch of credit uh gift cards one
day and we just went and [__] shop
till we dropped like we got [__] polo
shirts from boss dude I had Dockers
you're a scammer dude I was there like
six scams how'd you do that the outdated
flexes are so funny huh
so you buy it with a credit card and
then you can pick it up or you get it
mailed to you yeah imagine 12 year old
boys going to Tommy Bahama dude we were
at Hugo Boss and people just thought we
were like Rich Kids Hugo Boss yeah I got
Diesel Jeans baby I swear to God those
clothes last me like probably three four
years just like
because I was in junior high
a decade I didn't fit them anymore
Birkenstocks oh yeah it lasts me a while
that makes sense yeah I don't know and
then like I didn't know the severity of
what I was doing until like you got a
little older and you're just like oh
yeah and another thing that's straight
up fraud my buddy was like you [__]
you you you sent those things to your
house the FBI is Gonna Catch You like
you're not supposed to send it to your
house and I'm like you didn't tell me so
I'm like where did you send it because I
sent it to my neighbor's house and then
when the mail comes I grab their [__]
and I'm like
[__] I'm stupid he's so smart he got his
next door neighbor instead of him what a
genius I saw a lot of a lot of um like
young
ma kids I saw a scam where they'll like
steal stuff and then they'll give their
kids something with a beeper and they
walk through and it beeps and then they
go honey I'm I'm so sorry and they give
the Beeper and they're already through
it so it doesn't beat more for what they
actually whoa
so
wow you know what's crazy is like all
the times that I've had the beeping go
off and I'd stop and turn around and
they just go yeah and I'm like I could
have just had so much [__] it's like
crazy like
[Laughter]
you're good and then we go in the car
and we're like we're not good we gotta
get this [__] thing off our t-shirts
now and then you go back and they're
like they take it off for you and I'm
like come on man do your job for sure
we're not good
have you stole anything Colleen yeah in
high school I stole jewelry with a
friend but we were stupid we got caught
you got caught yeah it was Nordstrom
that's scary Nordstrom wow I bet your
heart
it was when we thought we got away
because like we got out of the story we
went down the escalator and then as soon
as we are like halfway down we just see
like the security guy just turn the
corner and just stand right in front of
the escalator and we were like [__] yeah
you're like putting necklaces on each
other yeah yeah how did you do it yeah
we were all [__] We're not gonna run
at this point you know
um
what was the question how'd you do it oh
we straight up just dumb just put it in
our pocket we're gonna look at that [__]
and there's just cameras right there
that's another thing too they're kind of
watching
that's my move dude that's what I do
exactly the cameras yeah estimate that a
little bit good look at you there are
some places that really have an actual
guy looking at the monitor which is
right yeah and I I think that was the
guy that died whether or not whether or
not the employees you know there's like
this is my chance to shine isn't there a
thing in California though where you can
like steal a certain amount and then
everyone was like stealing stuff now
they don't like 500 or some [__] yeah I
think they up it's 9 50. up Grand Theft
used to be five yeah now it's more where
are we going boys do more [__] dude I
think I think the klepto is coming back
at me everything's even talking about
this I'm like that's the same weight
like probably types of Target tight
Lucille's barbecue gift card
sir these are unloaded oh [__]
runs up to the register grabs the gift
cards and run and he's like guys I got
gift cards guys and then we're like
trying to eat good
thing on the card dude unlimited Lucille
again check again run for it the way
that uh the way that my friend uh used
to clean clean the serial numbers of TVs
it's pretty interesting he'll be able to
get us really cheap almost free TVs
practically free but um he would he
worked at Best Buy and they did this
thing back then where uh they would Mark
a TV as having to be returned and if you
return a TV they have to send it to the
refurbishing uh Center to verify that
everything works and it's all good right
even if they don't fix it they just have
to get a stamp so they just say oh this
is a return and instead of shipping it
to the refurbishing company they just
give it to someone else so so in the
system it'll be like oh refurbishing
still has it it's just held up there
yeah Whoa by the time anyone cares to
even look into it that TV's probably out
of style
you still got that homie no he actually
got caught and fired and everything yeah
they eventually like yeah because he did
it too much that's always the thing
right you do it a few times and then you
get more homies and then you get peer
pressure to do it more often and then
yeah damn it dude but yeah he was doing
that for quite a while on new TV
your teeth are so cheap you're such a
cheap ass Nick oh yeah I just want to
steal it bro I just want a good deal you
get like a 70 inch like 700 000 PTV
right now for like [__] 250 yeah and
if you want it used that's gonna cost
less than like most parking tickets